Guten Abend, ich bin Yahya Avci und ich bin der Dienstabenderarzt auf dieser Station.
Würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch hören. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja natürlich bin ich einverstanden.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Ja, danke schön.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie Ihre Fragen am Ende des Gesprächs oder Zwischen durchstellen.
Okay?
Okay.
Ja, so erst ich möchte Ihre persönlichen Informationen fragen.
Ja, okay.
Wie heißt denn Sie?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pohl.
Rudolf Pohl.
Ja, können Sie bitte Ihre Akfohr und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, das ist auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Der Vorname ist R-U-D-O-L-P-H.
Und dann geht es weiter, P-O-H-L.
Das ist vergleichsweise einfach.
P-O-H-L.
P-P-O-H-L.
Pohl.
Ja, okay.
Perpobium.
Wie heißt denn Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
57.
Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 16. Mai 65.
16. Mai.
Ja, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 82.
1 Meter 82.
Und wie viel wiegeln Sie?
89 Kilo.
89.
Wie ist Ihre Hausarzt, Herr Pohl?
Mein Hausarzt ist Dr. Behrens.
Dr. Behrens.
Was würdest du uns, welche Beschwerden haben?
Sie wissen ja, ich habe so tüchtigen Husten.
Das ist jetzt in den letzten Tagen so schlimm geworden.
Heute Morgen hatte ich dann auch mit einmal hohes Fieber.
Jetzt muss ich doch mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Ich habe auch so geschwitzt heute Nacht.
Mir tut alles weh beim Gusten.
Das ist jetzt wirklich von Tag zu Tag schlimmer geworden.
Sie haben gut entschieden, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ich kann gleich dazu sagen, ich habe einen Corona-Test gemacht.
Aber der war negativ.
Negativ, ja.
Das war natürlich mein erster Gedanke, als das mit dem Husten los.
Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Das hat vor fünf Tagen angefangen.
Vor fünf Tagen.
Und in der letzten Tag ist der Husten schlimmer geworden.
Es wird von Tag zu Tag schlimmer.
Jetzt tut das weh.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte heute Morgen hohes Fieber.
Heute Nacht habe ich ganz schlecht geschlafen, weil ich so geschwitzt habe.
Ich fühle mich auch richtig krank.
Ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Alles tut mir weh.
Sie haben Kopfschmerzen und haben Sie auch Brutzschmerzen?
Ja, beim Gusten tut es sehr weh.
Und Wolkenautos?
Eigentlich tut es überall weh.
Überall.
Sind die Schmerzen beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen verschlimmert?
Ja, ich atme gar nicht so tief ein im Augenblick.
Das macht sofort eine Hustenheit.
Es ist auch ein bisschen schmerzhaft.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie drückend, stehend, pochend?
Wie kann ich das beschreiben?
Ein bisschen brennend und drückend?
Ich merke einen Widerstand beim Husten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkale von 1 bis 10?
Wobei ein sehr lecker Schmerz ist und 10 unerträglich Schmerz ist.
Unerträglich ist das nicht, aber auf die Dauer ist es unerwinnend.
Ich würde sagen, bei 5 bis 6 oder so.
5 bis 6, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Das klingt so langsam an, aber gestern klingt es vielleicht anders.
Am Anfang denkt man, das geht wieder weg, aber heute ist es schlimmer geworden.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben auch Kopfschmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Die Kopfschmerzen sind im Vergleich bei 4 bis 5 oder so.
Ich fühle mich nur ein bisschen schlapp und krank.
Ist der Hustern mit oder ohne Ausruf?
Da kommt so viel grünes Zeug raus.
Ja, grünes.
Das ist ein bisschen eklig.
Sind die Hustern immer mit Ausruf?
Eigentlich erst seit ein paar Tagen am Anfang nicht, aber jetzt kommt immer so grünes Zeug raus.
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Nein, die Blut kam nicht.
Sie haben auch Fieber.
Ich habe gemessen, da hatte ich 39 ein.
Wir haben das gemessen, in der Achse oder in der Mund.
Sie haben auch Schutelfrost.
Sie haben auch Schutelfrost, aber geschwitzt?
Ja, geschwitzt.
Haben Sie auch Nachschweiß?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, wegen Hustern.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normalerweise habe ich gute Appetit, aber im Augenblick schmeckt es mir nicht.
Sind Ihre Brüste-Mersen tagsüber oder in der Nacht?
Wir sind insbesondere beim Husten und wenn ich tief einatne,
fällt mir das Nachts mehr auf, weil ich versuche zu schlafen.
Tagsüber sieht man etwas anderes, da fällt es eigentlich so auf.
Es gibt bestimmte Ausslöse, die ich mir nicht mehr verstanden habe.
Bei Belastung oder in der Ruhe?
Ich belaste mich nicht.
Ich habe mich geschont.
Wahrscheinlich wäre es schlimmer, wenn ich jetzt versuche, die Treppe hochzurennen.
Ich bin gestern nicht zu Arbeit gegangen und heute auch nicht.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, es wird ein bisschen besser, wenn ich etwas warmes trinke.
Dann ist für den Moment der Hustenreiz weg, aber das ist nur für den Augenblick.
Haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Das habe ich nicht, aber seit fünf Jahren ist es bekannt, dass ich unter Gift leide.
Ich muss vorsichtig essen.
Vor fünf Wochen hatte ich einen üblichen Anfall mit Schmerzen in einem Fuß, in einem Zähn.
Aber das ist zum Glück wieder vorbei.
Wann war das?
Vor fünf Wochen.
Ansonsten haben Sie keine Erkrankungen?
Ich habe ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen seit vielen Jahren bei Belastung und bei Kälte.
Wenn ich mich falsch bewege, habe ich mich schon fast dran gewöhnt.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte eine Kapaltunnel-Operation.
Das ist aber auch schon lange her.
Das war vor 13 Jahren.
13 Jahre.
War die Operationskompetition noch?
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut gewesen.
Ich habe auch etwas gebracht.
Ich arbeite viel mit den Händen.
Jetzt habe ich mir noch einmal ordentlich in den linken Daumen geschnitten.
Aber das passiert immer wieder.
Das ist akut noch so, dass es mit einem Pflaster versorgt ist.
Das wäre schon herrlich.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich bin zylori 300.
Zylorik 300?
Zylorik.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Dann habe ich noch so eine Sache.
Dafür nehme ich im Sommer so ein spezielles Hautgel.
Ich habe bei Sonne so eine Hautveränderung im Schläfenbereich.
Da kann ich die Sonne nicht vertragen.
Da muss ich dann diese Salbe auftragen.
Das heißt Solaratze gelten.
Solaras.
Könnte Sie bitte burschrabieren?
Ja, das heißt S-O-L-A-Z-E.
Das ist so ein Gel, das ich dann im Sommer auf die Stäfe aufschraube.
Ja, wegen Hautveränderung.
Ja, das reagiert auf Sonne.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch?
Also ich weiß, dass ich der Amoxicillin-Allergie habe.
Das darf ich auf keinen Fall bekommen.
Da kriege ich Ausschlag davon.
Und sind Sie gegen COVID-19?
Ja, ja.
Wie viel mal?
Dreimal.
Und war Sie schon einmal in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, in letzter Zeit war ich nicht im Ausland.
Rauchen Sie hervor?
Ja, zurzeit zwar nicht mit dem Husten, aber normalerweise rauchen ich schon.
Ich rauch zwar nicht so viel, aber halt doch schon viele Jahre lang.
Ja, und wie viel Zigarette und seit wann?
Ja, ich brauche jetzt fast 40 Jahre.
Und halbes Päckchen am Tag für dich.
Halbes Päckchen.
Aber das ist zu viel, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das nicht gesund ist.
Und jetzt, also im Augenblick schmeckt Zigarette auch wirklich nicht.
Ja, haben Sie schon einmal versucht, rauchen zu hören?
Aufzuhören, ja.
Einmal x mal, ja.
Aber es ist nicht so einfach.
Wenn Sie wollen, ja, am Ende des Gesprächs kann ich Ihnen ein Kleid geben, oder?
Ja, ja, das ist nie zu spät, ja.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also richtig scharfen Alkohol trinke ich nicht, aber abends im Bier trinke ich ziemlich rührendmäßig, ja.
Ja, abends ein Flaschebier.
Ja.
Und das ist eine rotine Frage, deswegen muss ich das fragen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nicht Drogen, nein, nein, mit Drogen habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie regelmäßig Ihren Hausarzt besucht?
Ja, oder weniger.
Mehr weniger, weniger, weniger.
Also die Rezepte kriege ich immer so an der Rezeption und dann sehe ich den Doktor nicht so oft.
Ja, okay.
Alle zwei Jahre mal.
Und haben Sie Ihre Vorsorge und Untersuchung gemacht?
Ja, da bin ich mal, da bin ich jetzt vor zwei Jahren mal gewesen, ja.
Ja, und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die leben beide noch, ja.
Und gibt es irgendwer, der chronisch Herr Franko?
Ja, mein Vater, der hat im Bergwerk gearbeitet.
Der hat eine Staublunge.
Staublunge.
Meine Mutter, die hatte jetzt vor vier Wochen gerade eine Operation.
Die hat den Darmenverschluss und musste halt da operiert werden.
Aber der scheint es jetzt wieder ganz gut zu werden.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Franko?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben drei Kinder, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wie man es nennt, das eine Kind hat Down-Syndrom.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite als Florist.
Florist?
Florist.
Ich arbeite als Blumengeschäft.
Ja, Florist, ja.
Ja, schon.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Wenn ich ehrlich bin, nicht so richtig, nein.
Also ich fahre manchmal mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit
oder am Wochenende mal mit dem Fahrrad mit den Kindern los.
Aber regelmäßig sporten mache ich eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Okay, Herr Paul, ich habe ein paar Fragen vergessen.
Ja, ist Ihre Ausruf, wie ist Konsistenz?
Das ist so gelblicher Schleimhalt.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, gelblicher Schleimhalt,
ja, nicht hart oder nicht zäftig.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und?
Und?
Jeder Husten.
Sind jeder Husten morgens,
meistens morgens oder abends oder tagsüber?
Also morgens, wenn ich aufwache,
huste ich wie verrückt, ja,
dann habe ich das Gefühl,
da muss ich nicht mehr aufwachen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe das Gefühl,
da muss ganz viel erst mal raus.
Aber auch wenn ich versuche,
abends einzuschlafen,
komme ich kaum zur Ruhe.
Tagsüber habe ich jetzt auch viel gehusstet, ja.
Okay, Herr Paul.
Ja, ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt eigentlich nur wissen,
was man tun kann dagegen.
Weil ich mich wirklich sehr schlecht fühle.
Und weil ich auch so das Gefühl habe,
ich kann einfach nicht mehr, ne?
Ja, ja.
Das ist so anstrengend, so erschöpftet dieser Abliste.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Ja, Herr Paul.
Ja, zuerst,
ja, eine Ritke Diagnose zu stellen.
Es ist so früh,
eine Ritke Diagnose zu stellen.
Aber ich habe eine Verdacht auf Pneumonie,
ihre Lungen entzündet.
Aber es muss bestätigt werden.
Zuerst werde ich die körperliche Untersuchung
danach bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und Röntgenaufnahme per annassen.
Danach werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt bestrechen
und ich komme wieder zurück.
Okay, gut.
Alles klar.
Haben noch Kollegen Fragen?
Haben Sie Luft noch?
Hat er eigentlich gesagt,
er kriegt schlecht Luft.
Er hat das nicht als Luftnot bezeichnet.
Ich muss so schnell atmen und ich kriege schlecht Luft.
Hat er?
Wann tritt die Luftnot bei Belastung oder Ruhe?
Ja, beim Husten.
Schon beim Husten kriegt er schon Luftnot.
Und Gewicht hat er nicht verändert.
Die Frage tauchte eben noch so auf.
Ich habe diese Simulation wieder gemacht.
Vor 3 Monaten.
Genau, 19.07.
Und dieses Thema,
unsere WhatsApp-Gruppe,
sehr lange diskutiert.
Ja, sie haben hier schon viel geredet.
Ich habe ein Patient gesagt, er habe Schmerzen in der Brust.
Zollte eine EKG,
z.B. in der Halb-8-Münütung,
geschrieben und mit einem Parameter gemessen werden.
Der Patient kommt Husten,
in die Brust,
sagt, ich habe Schmerzen in der Brust.
Wir reden noch, das ist nicht wahr.
Ah, okay.
Ja, wobei er hat ja eigentlich,
eigentlich hat er nichts,
hat er nichts gesagt,
was auf kardiale Beschwerden hinweist sonst.
Wenn man kardielle Probleme gibt,
oder nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Ist egal, man muss es auch alle Fälle machen.
Prädisposal und Risikofaktoren gibt.
57 Jahre, männliche,
und raucher.
Und alkoholik.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn ein Patient,
welcher alt, kein Problem,
welcher männlich oder weiblich, kein Problem,
Brust Schmerzen in der Notaufnahme kommt,
muss man, ja, eine EKG.
Ja, auf jeden Fall eine EKG schreiben.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Simulation,
Husten.
Das kann man nur nicht lange machen.
Ja, hier warten und reden.
Okay, ja.
Also, wenn es in der Prüfung kommt,
hängen Sie den Patienten erst an Monitor.
Ja, Monitor.
Man kann sagen, ja, Herr Pol, ich werde ja,
ich sehe, dass Sie Husten haben und wir sehen,
ein bisschen ja,
ja, wir müssen Ihre Dauer-
Stofftätigung messen.
Ja, bitte.
Können wir Arsatzkischwürde anfangen,
Frage Erhild.
Von mir aus immer, das ist die Frage, ob Herr Arsatz so weit ist.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Oberarsten, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Aber natürlich.
Die Patientin ist 57 Jahre, jährige Patientin.
Ein Meter, ja, Patient.
Ein Meter 82 groß und 89 Kilo schwer.
Er stellte wegen seit fünf Tagen,
seit fünf Tagen,
bestehende, akut auftretender
im laufenden Zeit,
ja, oder sich in der Zeit
verstärkte Husten
und Fieber vor,
ja,
ja...
der habe...
ja,
die Atemabhängigkeit
Belastung abhängiger bei fünf bis sechs auf einer Schmerzkala legende
Torakalgi und Dusbne, so wie Sephalgi.
Er erwähnte, der Husten sei mit grünen Schleimen gewesen.
Aber er habe das Blut nicht bemerkt.
Er hat kein Blutigar.
Er hat keine Blutigar ausgeworfen.
Und Torakalgi war heute schlimm geworden.
Er erklagte auch Pyrexin 39,1 Axilla und Nachschweiß,
in der Petenz und die Husten bedingten in so einem Blut.
Ansonsten war die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Der Patient hat Corona Test gemacht.
Oder der Patient habe negative Corona Test ergeben.
Er gab in der Vorerkrankung für fünf Wochen Lumbargie seit vielen Jahren.
Und in der Operation geschieht,
er zeigte sich karpaltes Zünderung vor 30 Jahren.
Es war kompliziert.
Er ernehmete Siklorid 300 mg.
Was lassen Sie im Labor noch untersuchen?
Ich möchte gerne auch der Sputumkultur veranlassen.
Sehr gut.
Um eine erregende Bestensverordnung.
Um eine richtige und sichere Diagnose zu stellen,
werde ich von Torax veranlassen.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Der Patient wird stationär aufgenommen.
Und eine Flüssigkeit in Physiotherapie veranlässt.
Worauf achten Sie da?
Der Patient hat Amoxilin allergie.
Deswegen würde ich Makrolit beginnen.
Was tritt der noch für Medikamente?
Für seine Symptome.
Wir wollten Antikussifen und Makrolitik.
Was geben Sie für Makolusen?
Als der Zivilisator.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Dann hoffen wir, dass der bald wieder auf dem Weg der bessere Ruhe ist.
Ich habe nur ein paar Sachen auf den Blick.
Dann habe ich einen Nikotin.
Er hat 40 Jahre in halbis Päckchen geraucht.
Wie lange hatte er die Gicht?
Vor fünf Wochen.
Vor fünf Wochen hatte er einmal einen Gicht-Anfall.
Aber die Gicht wurde schon vor fünf Jahren diagnostiziert.
Vor fünf Wochen war ein Akuta.
Das war das einzige, was ich gefunden habe.
Das war alles perfekt gekommen.
Sie haben nichts ausgelassen.
Auch Familie, Anamnese, alles richtig mit den Fach gegriffen.
Das ist sehr gut gelaufen.
Sie haben sprachlich ganz wenige Schwierigkeiten.
Es ist alles gut verständlich.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen.
Das ist ein bisschen langweilig.
Sie machen sich nicht so schwer mit diesem berühmten ersten Satz.
Er stellte sich wegen.
Seit fünf Tagen bestehen im Husten.
Jetzt akut aufgetretenen Fieber.
Dann können Sie sagen, der Husten ist produktiv.
Der Auswurf ist schmerzhaft.
Sie machen nicht einen langen Satz.
Was hat er gesagt?
Ich bin immer für überschaubare Sätze.
Dann lieber noch mal etwas nachschieben.
Dann sind die Sätze klarer verständlich.
Es muss nicht alles im ersten Satz gesagt sein.
Das schafft man gar nicht.
Ich finde es viel übersichtlicher, wenn man den ersten Satz nicht so lange macht.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich Ihnen als Empfehlung geben würde.
Natürlich sollten Sie aufnehmen den Vorschlag von Herrn Dr.
Günthes.
Packen Sie den Patienten erst mal zur Kontrolle.
Dann diskutieren Sie weiter mit Ihnen.
Alles klar.
Sie müssen genauso wenig wie Ihre Frau Angst haben.
Sie schaffen das.